To try to motivate this idea
let's look at a little example.
So let's imagine we've got two agents,
agent 1 and agent 2.
And agent 1 has kind of a goal or
some kind of reward
function that it's running.
And to make that reward function have
high reward, agent 1 needs an apple.
Now the apple is not far away but
it is very close to agent two.
So what are some things that agent
one could do to satisfy its goal.
>> It could walk over to the apple.
>> Good, anything else?
Well, once it gets there can say I
thought you were giving me an iPad and
then kick agent 2 and run.
>> [LAUGH]
I see, wrong apple.
This is the food kind of apple.
But, you're right that probably
this particular agent 1 would
would like an Apple watch.
>> Yes, well actually this particular
agent 1 has an Apple watch.
Then let's see,
the other thing that could happen is
agent 1 could ask agent 2
To bring him the apple.
>> Good and I guess presumably each one
could just also just do nothing and
just wait for agent two to for
the apple to just show up using artwork.
Like maybe agent two would bring it by-
>> I guess it maybe not apples but like
all men's there's certainly agents that
bring each one home mints and ice cream.
>> Yeah.
Have you got ice cream in while?
Okay, and then yes.
That's too bad looks like your looks
like your Apple Watch exploded.
>> That's okay,
I'll just get another one.
>> Yeah, because this one's broken.
Anyway, when we're doing planning or
sequential decision making we need
to decide amongst these different
options if you will or different
courses of action that we could take.
How do we usually do that in the
framework that we've been talking about?
>> Well, if we're living in an MDP like
world we actually define the MDP and
I think the secret sauce there is to
figure out what the right rewards are.
>> Right.
>> And the reason I said it that way is
because in the game theory case we
usually call those utilities and
not rewards, and I just want to
differentiate between the two of them.
Okay and then what we do with those?
>> Well once we have rewards or
utilities we then find
a policy that maximizes them.
We maximize our reward actually
as we maximize our utility.
>> It seems like we could do this sort
of thing in the scenario where we've got
multiple agents and
they need to coordinate and
communicate with each other.
But it turns out it starts to get
a little bit hard to define exactly what
the costs are, and was the likelihood
that this is actually going to work and
so forth.
So what we're going to do
is actually think about
just like we did when
we talked about POMDPs.
We said that they allow us to strike a
balance between actions to gain reward.
And actions to gain information and we
don't have special like a special other
way of reasoning about that all of
that being folded into one model.
Where actions are being taken and
they might have informational impact and
they might have reward impact.
The informational impact is subservient
to the reward in a sense right so
the agent just tries to figure out.
I will take an action to gain
information if it helps me get more
reward in the long run.
And so,
the DEC-POMDPs is a similar sort of idea
that's going to let us put coordinating
and communicating along with
actions that they may become actions
just like everything else like this.
Ask for it becomes a kind of action and
walk to Apple becomes a kind of action,
and the agents can reason about
whether that's a good idea or
not depending on how to
maximize their utility.
>> Sounds promising.